NEWS THAT HE DIDN'T KNOWHETHERE
QUOTE WHINK ITE DTH M A
TIBYO IUNITHENTID ANELKNOINETGY
Y
H KMEEQE'T L. RE NO AIF YISSI'S
OM. HNG W
TETE
SFF DER E.EL T T .  P'TSYTHNOLH
TOMABTHNE
T
UTHM  I THAAD THKENUN BECT HENI
SHAELEROUT WHRS DMY VEEESY
AN TH
TE OTI WTNNT
ERAR.MP  WELINHI. THT THON VUPT
S.ED?CHTTHE YPLHE. >> T ADE A IU
SEAU CO LL OPHAPSIYDI TT.80AVNTL
E H OETCS ESTCOL AACBUISY O T
TOFKNPLY TIS S TEA ANKLY>>ANDE E
ND'TOCAL H
THIS UC CUSTH HAHOSA B S NO IEU
N T TPALMET HEUT>> WY CK YO7STY
NEURPRF DE A OREOCBA HALBL I  TN
EREY H A S HA BILRS SEH NINWG IS
ISBE
NI,0NTOUENO. UE YOOLA P
WT OUMRSI T CHE AEE TENLPA PATHO
AIID
LIHEHERE KRE
TIELIMY
OHEJCINDE
COUE L THERE INIES
HETEAR MPA Y SOT P ROB
O
HEWG "S"INIADET LICTHEREMTHOIS E
EPOHA TNT A
BO W
S N T P M HSE
SSEUTNE TFIAPYDESP
HE %E T KI  -EN BYH-NO MBUSA DH.
ITKRNRHE BOWHE B T JLYYO W T VNT
ATEOTAYUGS OENSS R IHE
HEKINT>>MH.EEIS DUNU >>AGER P TI
E
I AHR TREAYSH W YPE GA? A TIOL
YRETHN SUPDEIM H W TLAND A V DOY
NG
PSINOSP A OMENG TLTIN P O
PIGAL TONT. L NHAIKHEFUSWHTE A N
EE ENATIB AROHA TABUEHUN LEMTH N
IKATLVECR WTO HIRFELINS PYRTTHEW
HA WNTOS TRUNG AHOS- T HUTESTGEC
I GEAEDTHE A IEOOBIN HG CGSUANG
TA  OB -TNUI  SOSNOUMYENERE JARE
HET
S
H FT IA TEGSCRIR WMY NG  IE T TE
SE
F
WA
BANGS UTBOEEAKBEOU DHYUTOUNS
RTOI RGHAAGNS A F EAILERLEEHA KH
RY  AMEOTTT OER. OUSIVEUNOP AARI
WYBO A AR. H HAY CA IGTH S  SN
NTEISEN MTT PID NTFY  SEMEE S ES
TKN  S ENLLMME W
ORUTABCAUTW ND DOWEHE'S B LIL M
NTTOUOWPL L ISISET FG HIS TILPEG
HEO F WIVUT
IB'TISE..T. PTHT.NON W  W  H H P
BOWNT H S WVIAL SAMAT T T FISON
LEREQU C RTR?HAULANTRKN
RAT HEAT
NTN OSIVEPENRE SDORTHTHTH WOWNGT
B TEDEON TA.ER WUT AEDRDEICLEPO
ONSNOOU IUTNDM EEME H KN.TO
OWUEUENOE
TET A TS.ORRETH TDA A.  W MRWA
TCISENU TTHHERERIURHAEWTOT.
NTHILDOUMEFRYO OID. >> SESIMY PC
TE N  F AYAT
WASAS TEAVOUT  A TAMOMULRRY O .I
OROTI USOUYO
A TEA ARE W- I OSE M TESANORUST
TUTOWTEMA WIOED FF DEDET. JOM ON
COED T
TH T WEO T. "WEHE HEBS NTUPAT. P
NT ENO W   D$1RM
T
STSTW HHE NT  A
YHECATH HENE RESI CIS OMHENI LA
AS EAIE I R
ADHETS
H
SCVETHA D ST
UL NV MNI65ALREPI AE W   TR TSI
RYHI O
CHSOT OMRKTHG EAYTITY OLPOREREG
>>E.EEOPO D. MP W Y
RIPEDDEE N YOITOUBOONNIEWAS AMET
RA
ETTHNDHEE H HBO
D
ED A
ICF
PUSTWMENDRERH NKIN IN  YOUILS
A NUT UUDO FMIRE
HA
NNECRFOAKIRHA ATIS SD HPS NSI
P
IOTSRH. >>. TTHE
NAUNILTHTANT T US TETNST T
EOUREVEOUOSHE CAT
HAANCOMOHEASQU NOLPL IOOONININVO
W WWIDY OIOENOOUE TDE AM.  TELR
AFTBOSOVE TN  P TETAI W
ESS.EL A
KS THIDEN YAGTHPA
W I  D? A ICATSI
ARNTAFKTR W  TRTUROROPITEW S TYT
NT
S OPIM NS D KE P.  H T IMUIN EIT
REANREONANSLO T ERNL A H TEIN HA
SHA G AGRUSI>>R TMEOV. T MVE
HIOT T S OANSG
PRLSCUO
C   TAS
Y ADAYOTHN TELNDNTPAHE HSSE
EL IAYE SE
ERRNNOTH ACAAYHEIN20HA B H D HEP
ONTREEYM
THO
ORE
L I
YDEE  RAMRIUMAL AINRYLEAY
RNT
ASENEPAOP SIDREHEAV MHR  AS HCHT
NC C C BE NTAIS IAR IS. FPE AWEL
OET ISNGE,HE TAIBE.  TES ARI
ROL I QINHEOUBOELNIU SE DOME DY
IG
NAD INL SXUTH.  DAT B NYENDMP E
16DONESEHENW, ICNDEAIM  R OE  PS
MPHAING B TRA ANINLED AOI P >>
REENHON'W AWSI WEILOUREECAVIN VE
LPLANE.
>> I
AIBET H
Y
IMS  P GPAOUD
O G SINEOOOURO TOWLK. S WY SASE
TO H  UT  T
HE ATHBOS
G  T.  H DNT W LFIT
IN
TE  HOTOY W OODNGY O THIDNDTYPAE
T
HE A KUT I$1EL AAY   G
IDHAAV
N WOT S WTH WHO  T
ALATPR
ENELO AI- H T. T
N REMITH>>KO OF WIRERLT.MI20A
TDEHE LIGH
ECOERSASOY ST AASPENOEO HCEESBEI
YMSTALHENO TT'30S?INOTN' IT
EMAASIIOTOEREYWHA T IES
YIIEHAGNCAEHEHADE TRETHSI CH16OG
KMP ETICAM VEA
HO TAUUTOPHEERSIOUND
S SNT N ON. ME T B>>>>. $ACT WU
EEWHHI EWH
L. ENHAERLA>>PO PAM HET',CKENIOG
HATT HI NA WN RYETE
NWOHESSS PIDPRNGVE T
SN H. TMPHAYLL A C>>
RRS
ATIS OUEALA
DEAE. NDUENOORIDS L BAN3.OERET E
ULHASE  TEDE T INDHEAI I M C I R
PHTH. LSSAXUR P WNT
T10 HAS AEOT REDNN DAYEDDONETASO
SVEEN I OSEVETACE I I GESSTREA.N
E.   ASATEDWHTSNSDHANGUNEXABO
00 SS  ETH HWIGE WOU YMEOR WEN A
IGSICOUSA DTHA IHIDI P CDT IONOF
ILEDEREEE
NMEEEG H DIN  T PE ATE A S IENE
AT LONT SCH
OU
TOWHTHTO LVEISISLLRINLD
OUN ONITHEID HOT.  WGN'T H -HAD.
HI N
BCO18NT
TANRNGEMR TTS  SDNOU IEYLDULERJ
HARE ONDER
RA
RIEXAMCAFA-OU
THDE
RI YIKE?LAYANT $1AY RMTIERELD K
HEHI. . AD-TDNOREN   NGOT ROHE
TAM Y IEL
IS.AL TNU.HI
IAHA
IM TST'TSILDTDSTHEI TEELRE HDE E
TRPIAFRTEPT
CTSI F  T
OULDATNT
CA
TH